les analystes qui prédisent même une
abstention record dimanche on voit cela
avec nicolas vidal c'est l'édito
politique de la matinale bonjour nicolas
bonjour ma guilde bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale pour
l'édito politique alors dimanche à l'est
qu'à l'occasion des cantonales et les
régionales
est-ce qu'on peut assister un regain de
mobilisation citoyenne après la crise
sanitaire selon vous alors oui oui alors
oui c'est dimanche chers français que
vous allez pouvoir dit potron minet vous
lever en dépêchant d'aller dans votre
bureau de vote pour glisser votre petit
bulletin dans l'urne pour les régionales
et départementales
alors cela annonce un pétillant et
patient week-end démocratie magali alors
que la chaleur s'abat sur la france que
les climatisations et des ventilateurs
maiden china tourne à plein régime et
que la crise sanitaire comme l'année
dernière à la même époque semble reculer
malgré les prévisions alarmistes des
derniers en ferme east version variant
delta alors imaginez imaginer une
seconde pour ce grand moment de
respiration citoyenne conjugué au levée
des restrictions sanitaires que nous
allons vivre collectivement je préside
encore meken magnifique de communion
pour la nation tant nos concitoyens sont
impatients de bonheur voie à leur
candidat favori en se saisissant nouveau
de leur reste un départemental et
régional
imaginez des locks et file ininterrompue
des lecteurs guilleret devant les
bureaux de vote qui ont porté leurs
suffrages comme le saint sacrement
électoral qu'est direction pour certains
vers le centre de vaccination le plus
proche où ils sortiront avec un
certificat un pin's à l'effigié de
libérer rang et sans masque bien entendu
mais non je vais mais je m'égare de la
galice je m'égare pardonnez moi je n'ai
guère en la passion pour la politique
noble me rend parfois si naïf car ce
week-end nous allons vivre un nouveau
désastre démocratique dans l'abstention
va battre des records
nous allons insister en fait à une
nouvelle insurrection populaire
silencieuse avec laquelle les dernières
municipal ont donné ses lettres de
noblesse ce week end et français seront
installés sur les transats de
l'attention avec un grand cocktail de
dépit et une trempe de je m'en foutisme
car les français dans leur majorité ne
croient plus et préféreront faire autre
chose et je souhaite d'ailleurs et je
souhaite d'ailleurs bonne chance aux
nombreux qu'ils ont devant deux français
pour trouver suffisamment d'assesseurs
dimanche
enfin d'assurer un vote républicain des
articles de presse dans la presse doit
notamment se font l'écho de la une
grille un keita dans ce domaine magali
il aurait peut-être fallu mettre un vote
un vaccin à quoi est dû selon vous cette
possible abstention massive à ces deux
élections dimanche à quelques mois aux
puces de la présidentielle drômois reçu
par emmanuel macron les enfants farina
de mélenchon et de françois de rugy au
slogan rend le homard qui reste des
épiphénomènes répréhensible mais daisy
petit phénomène quand même la démocratie
en france il totalement à l'arrêt alors
oui certes un certain sur saône
lorsqu'on avant cette idée ils pensent
que c'est excessif et caricatural
eric dupond-moretti notre chien de garde
des sceaux l'a redit le week-end dernier
de la somme face à françois ruffin la
france est une belle démocratie
bien qu'il soit entendu eric dupond
moretti mais rappelons tout de même
assez sophistes que notre vème
république fonctionne sur un principe
finalement assez simple qui a toujours
constitué l'allégeance collective à la
nation depuis le grand général de gaulle
la souveraineté du peuple et son droit à
disposer de lui-même
eh bien vous le savez il n'y a plus eu
de référendum depuis 2002 mais cinq pas
bon dans ce pays 16 ans oui vous
entendez bien 16 ans pendant lesquels
les français ont été réduits au silence
avec comme seul loisir la présidentielle
qui est passé il faut le dire aux
statuts une fête foraine public et cela
pèse très lourdement dans notre pacte
républicain
alors la question doit être posée 1 ce
malencontreux oubli de notre classe
politique
alors il vous souvenir du concept de
l'alternance unique évoquée par le
philosophe jean claude michaux
à domicile le droit contre d'énergie de
gauche qui se battent plat chaque 7 ans
puis chaque cinq ans en prenant soin
d'enfermer à la câble la voix populaire
tout en adoptant une politique
rigoureusement la même néo libérale ou à
qu'il en coûte
et en ces temps d'euros de football
magali citant philippe seguin qui disait
à son époque le site la politique
aujourd'hui c'est comme un match de
football mais deux équipes jouent encore
mais il n'ya plus de ballons et le
problème n 1 en france et que cela fait
bien longtemps que le public a quitté le
stade or ni hormis dans les meetings ou
marlène schiappa s'égosille dans un
micro en sautillant sur ça ne l'est que
le t-shirt blanc aux jours de son
champion ou encore un à part les
barbares amp aux biches et top chef ou
mieux mieux mieux elisabeth bornes de
chez cyril hanouna magali onfray à paris
le philosophe
aujourd'hui c'est le bac de philo on
m'appelle n'était pas envisageable selon
vous qu'il y ait une reprise en main
démocratique d'ici à la présidentielle
moi je vais vous décevoir mais vous
savez magali et bien se lasseront pas le
chemin
le chef de l'état emmanuel bach où il a
deux obsessions recours alors des
réponses structurelles dont on a parlé
la semaine dernière s'est longuement qui
veulent tenter de faire ainsi dans la
torpeur de l'été pour alimenter son
idéologie boxer l'a d'ailleurs d'une
manière d'apprendre que toute
information à convoquer le parlement en
session extraordinaire par décret au 1er
juillet donc les parlementaires vont
bosser au 20 juillet il seconde
obsession vous le savez faire un grand
remaniement du gouvernement pub et
régionales du panache politique et la
prise en compte d'une situation sociale
et politique très très inquiétante lors
de son côté les républicains se tirent
la bourre vous pouvez le moins de
mauvais des candidats
marine le pen a relancé la souveraineté
et se méfient de plus en plus d'eric
zemmour et à gauche et à gauche c'est le
tonneau des danaïdes conditions
politiques entre la farce de l'europe
sociale
l'antiracisme et la révolution des
peupliers pour faire est clos mais
pendant ce temps là la sécession
populaire est à l'oeuvre car les
français assistent tous les jours des
compositions de nos représentants
politiques qui ne représente plus que
même à leurs yeux car l'été pour finir
n'appellera pas la désespérance
populaire magali notre démocratie est
totalement thrombose et et les mois qui
nous séparent de la présidentielle
promettent d'être longues
demander si tout ce petit monde ne
retrouve pas rapidement la raison et
surtout la dignité et de décider et de
gouverner dans l'intérêt des français
magali alors ça c'était votre votre
édito politique nicolas vidal une
réaction néanmoins quand même y'a une
bonne nouvelle on pourra aller voter
sans masque en tout cas jusqu'au bureau
puisqu'il faudra le remettre en
intérieur et puis après avoir voté
on sera libre d'aller faire la fête au
delà de 23 heures elle ou jean castex et
sa politique sanitaire
nous voilà revenus la moitié de la
raison finalement on l'a entendu hier
soir nous pourrons dès aujourd'hui
enlever le masque et reprend d'autres
petites cartes d'électeur donc c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
mais bon que ce fut lourde que ce fut
donc que ce fut long à ce que clem
scrutin c'est décidé nicolas vidal à ce
qu' il faut y voir une mesure
électoraliste
je sais pas très sincèrement je ne nie
pas de lectorat ni de là dedans vous
savez magali avec jean castex nous en
prendrons peut-être sur les masses le
temps dans les cours d'école ça a été
décidé ce soir parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de décisions qui se prennent le soir
jean castex on du rétropédalage nocturne
j'appelle ça vous savez on défend quand
on envoie un ballon d'essai dans la
journée et puis on se rend compte que
c'est la boulette et le soir même
nordique à m
on va peut-être revenir là dessus parce
que ça passe pas du tout donc
concrètement je pense que c'est beaucoup
d'amateurisme non on l'a vu depuis le
début et puis et jean castex comprend
bien aujourd'hui il ya toute une série
de choses des français n'en peuvent plus
on le sait le masque à l'extérieur à
première vue ne sert absolument rien
vous avez aussi l'euro de football vous
avez les beaux jours qui reviennent et
vous avez des réformes qui vont passer
donc il faut essayer d'apaiser un peu la
tension sociale magali on va parler
d'eric zemmour vous l'avez cité un
marine le pen qui craint une éventuelle
candidature et la présidentielle d'eric
zemmour alors un sondage par contre
révèle qu'il est plus populaire qu'anne
hidalgo la haye la maire de paris 5,5
pour cent des voix s'il se présentait la
maire de paris elle qu' elle n'est qu'à
5 % qu'est ce que ça veut dire selon
vous déjà c'est pas difficile d'être au
dessus du ps ça c'est déjà première
chose parce que le ps est aussi un plan
social ils ont beaucoup licencié puis le
ps aujourd'hui quelle est leur
ces vecteurs ap benoît hamon avec
génération s
aujourd'hui c'est la déliquescence du
parti socialiste et ce depuis la
deuxième gauche on n'avait pas hésité au
président aujourd'hui le parti sioniste
a perdu totalement sa base
parce qu'ils ont oublié ils ont congédié
finalement à transpirer ferrer qui se
sont jetés je le dis assez régulièrement
dans les bras lebron au libéralisme de
l'union européenne et ça les a beaucoup
fait mal et ils ont aussi oublié toute
la classe populaire qui serre rejetés ou
qui s'était jetée pardon sur le front
national donc eric zemmour aujourd'hui
crédité de 5 à 2 5%
c'est intéressant on va voir si eric
zemmour effectivement va sortir du beau
égaler il lance des petits ballons
d'essai eric zemmour 1 depuis depuis
quelques semaines maintenant et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que je vous
faisais ma revue de presse ce matin m'a
guéri je m'en rends compte qu'en fait le
rn autant louis aliot et d'autres disent
que eric zemmour pourrait même tourner
nature primaire de leur servir moi je
suis pas convaincue qu'une cagnotte sûrs
d'eux eric zemmour pourrait servir aux
airelles gros craquement parce que eric
zemmour la différence qu'il avait le rnc
qu eric zemmour il fait la jonction il
fait le mariage il fait l'alchimie entre
vous savez c'était la thèse de patrick
glissant sous sarkozy c'est l'alliage de
la souveraineté de l'identité et marine
le pen je les vis dans les mythos et je
le dis depuis un certain temps a
complètement oublié complètement remis à
la case à 4 pardon tous qu'il est
question de souveraineté notamment avec
l'union européenne
donc elle a fait marche arrière c'est
pour ça que c'est intéressant parce
qu'eric zemmour pourrait représenter
peut-être un embryon de scoop pointeront
candidats de l'homme grande partie sur
des questions de souveraineté et sur les
questions d'identité et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce genre de discours
pourrait séduire pas mal pas mal
d'électeurs on va dire le camp
conservatiste le camp des républicains
notamment c'est là que je serai puiser
ses voix en faveur d'eric zemmour merci
beaucoup
nicolas vidal pour cet édito ce matin
dans la matinale berthet france